[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
vans troy aikman the hall of famer he
was on the call last night buck
saints and he'll be at lambeau next
sunday the nfc conference championship
game between the buccaneers packers at 3
eastern on fox
troy thanks for joining us um what
advice would you give
drew brees today if he asked for it
uh take some time away and just give it
some real thought i mean i i know he's
been thinking about this for a long time
he's been
he's been doing it a long time of course
uh
but i think he just needs to get away
and let some time pass
it's hard to make these kinds of
decisions uh after a tough loss like
what he just experienced
but you went through this even when you
retired and then you flirted with coming
back
like what is that what is that urge that
you got with those two or three
different times where you thought about
it
yeah well the first one was san diego
with the chargers it was uh
as soon as i got released by the cowboys
i had considered going to the chargers
and then they ended up signing doug
flutie and that was actually
drew brees's rookie year they drafted
through that year we would have been
teammates had i've gone
um but it was a couple years later when
i heard from andy reid and the
philadelphia eagles and then a year
after that my third year out when
when dave wanstead and norv turner were
with the dolphins and
and asked if i would consider coming out
and and i think what it is dan is
is for me i was actually 34 uh when i
retired so
to to still feel like you can do it and
and have your health
and then miss the competition of it you
just you know now
i'm fully satisfied in my job of
broadcasting but early on
it was hard walking out of a stadium and
not knowing whether you had won or lost
but
i think for drew because of his age you
know he's
uh 42 years old that that
the the days are kind of um you know not
totally he could still play another year
of course but he's not going to have the
window
of opportunity i just didn't want to
look back and just think
man i i wish i'd given it another shot
in hindsight i'm glad i didn't do it
uh but at the time it was uh it was a
real urge and i was going to do it for
the dolphins
at the end of the day rick spillman was
the general manager and and he's the one
who ultimately just couldn't pull the
trigger on it
they thought they were a quarterback
away from going to the super bowl
but as it turned out they they really
were not that good i think the team went
six and ten that season and
and so as i watched the dolphins play
that year i thought wow i'm really glad
i don't think
i wouldn't have made a big difference to
that team but i wonder about drew brees
you walk off the field you don't want to
walk off this way
at home three interceptions but when you
win troy
there's part of you that says like i
want to do it again like
why like elway you know limped away
he didn't walk away he limped away after
winning uh peyton knew he couldn't play
anymore
like it feels like that's the only way
you can walk away
from winning is if you're barely able to
walk away
i agree with you and it's a great point
i if you would ask me early in the
season
midway or so if i thought tom brady was
going to come back even though he gave
the bucks a two-year commitment
i would have said it's 50 50. as much as
tom has said he's going to play for x
number of years
now he's having the most fun he's had
and they're winning that
there's no way he's not going to come
back next year so and and i agree with
you as far as it goes for
for drew that i mean that is it
it's been an amazing career of course
the all-time leading pastor
but that was one of his worst games of
his career it was the worst game of the
season
and to have that be your final
performance
and go out you know short of winning the
super bowl you're going to go out
not having one but i i would that's
going to naught him there's no he's a
great competitor and a real
disappointment i don't think ultimately
that's going to be decisive
in whether or not he decides to come
back how dangerous is brady
uh well he's real dangerous i i just
think that
i commented on it early in the game that
i thought those two quarterbacks for
young quarterbacks to watch and kind of
emulate as far as how they play the game
i i think tom having had a number of
conversations with him about the
position
there's a reason why he's won as many
games as he has and yes he's had good
players around him he's had good
coaching around all those things but
tom understands all the little details
of the game and what it takes to play
winning football
and and he did that uh in the biggest
game of the year for
for him yesterday would you rather have
a quarterback mentally tough or
physically
uh mentally yeah i
i think that uh i think that all the
quarterbacks in our game are physically
tough i think to get to even the nfl you
have to have some
some amount of toughness some some are
able to play through things
more than others but i i think more
today than even when i played and i
thought that when i played things were
kind of hard but with social media
and all of the critics out there i think
mentally you've got to be really really
strong to play this game
well i look at lamar jackson at this
same age aaron rodgers had thrown one
touchdown and one interception at age
24.
now we're questioning if lamar jackson
can win a big game
yeah are we being fair given the talent
he has
in the resume the brief resume winning
an mvp that
he should be winning these games
no i don't think it's fair i mean you
think back uh i think
peyton manning lost his first three
playoff games you know and some people
were questioning that now
you laugh at that when you think about
it that peyton manning was ever
questioned for anything and
you know we're quick now even when guys
come into the league as rookies we
we within a couple of games i hear
people start to comment on whether or
not a guy's a bust or not
i mean there's a number of us uh me
certainly being one of them that had
that been the criteria back when we
began our careers
we never would have but we never would
have made it you know they would have
replaced us really early on so yeah i
think it's uh
i think it is very unfair but i i also
know it's what everyone signs up for and
they understand it
lamar had a concussion this weekend
patrick mahomes had a concussion
you've had your history of concussions
do you know you have a concussion in the
moment
uh you know something's not right i i
know that for mine i always say this i
had two
really serious concussions i think all
head injuries are serious so
i don't want that to be misinterpreted
but the others that i had
whether it was five or six or whatever
it was uh i think we're
pretty minor but yeah you know that
something's not quite right
uh it's it's not a guessing game i think
for the one who has one
but did you try to go back in uh yeah
i think you know the trainers now now
more than ever they're really good about
it and then they've got a third party
that's able to evaluate the player and
decide whether or not he's capable of
coming back and playing
uh i i think the league's made great
strides in in that regard
um there was a time i mean even all the
all
the i have i had a concussion in the
championship game uh to where i still
have no recollection of having played in
that game
total amnesia from that game and yet i
played the very next week in the super
bowl there was no bye week so
i never missed a game the following week
following a concussion and i think
that's where things have really improved
that these players have to go through a
protocol
and uh you know it's it's stringent but
i think that's good
did you go back and watch the tape of
the game that you don't remember yeah i
did i did we got to atlanta the week of
the super bowl and i uh i i put on the
game
pretty pretty surreal experience when
you're watching a play
you know you don't remember any of these
throws i actually played good too
you and joe buck should announce that
game so you can actually critique
yourself in the moment there
wow that's uh um
troy's gonna be on the call with joe
buck the bucks and the packers at three
eastern
at lambeau field playing in the snow um
how big a deal those conditions how big
a deal is that
you know you have tom whose blood is
probably thinned out in tampa
you know we make a big deal about it
playing in the cold weather uh is that
that big a deal uh i i
i think it's a pretty big deal i think
because of the game
being the nfc championship game i think
the players you know they won't even
really be thinking of that much you'll
be so excited about the fact that
that they're one game away from from
realizing a real goal and a dream for
for all those guys but but yeah it's
real and i know that uh the packers
i mean the packers don't like the cold
any more than anyone else they're just
they're just more accustomed to it you
know they'd much rather prefer to play
in the 70 degree weather you know but i
i know that there's a confidence that
comes with it they wear it kind of as a
badge in
in green bay aaron rodgers certainly
does uh
but i i think the fact that tom has
played in the northeast as long as he
has and played in those conditions he's
aware of it he'll be able to communicate
that to some of those players who aren't
accustomed to it
and i think tom will will play well as a
result of it i think he's actually
very much looking forward to the
conditions how do you explain aaron
rodgers
if somebody never saw him play troy and
you were trying to sum it up
in 30 seconds how would you do that i i
think he's got a coolness to him you
know i mean i just don't see him get
flustered it just seems like he's always
holding the winning hand and and he
knows it you know to where there's a
confidence about him
regardless of whatever's happening in
the game that that he's going to pull it
out
and i know that's how i feel when i go
on to broadcast one of his games
that he's done so much i i he's the mvp
of the league in my opinion i said that
uh
probably with a month left in the season
when there was a lot of other people
being discussed
and the reason being that he just
doesn't have the same supporting cast
and it's nothing against
those players but when you compare you
know what they've had
there in green bay relative to some
other teams a lot of their success
understandably is the quarterback but i
think
more so than maybe some of the other
teams were
where they've gone on and had success
and have great players at the
quarterback position
what does buffalo have to do assuming
patrick mahomes is healthy what would be
your game plan in kansas city
well you know dan we had that game in
the regular
season a thursday night matchup there in
buffalo and
buffalo was determined not to give up
the big play which is priority number
one when you're playing kansas city of
course
but to my surprise andy reed just
continued to run the football and that's
not really andy's style either you know
he's always been criticized about
getting away from the run they ran the
ball i think they ran it for over 200
yards that night i
would have to go back and look but so i
think that the game plan works i think
if a team just runs the ball
that it's hard to score a lot of points
as long as they're not getting big runs
that i i think they did a good job in
that regard they got to shore some
things up uh with the run game
and then just play smart i think when
you get into january football
as we saw yesterday in our game the the
takeaways and the turnovers are huge i
mean really huge they're huge every week
but the the difference in these teams is
so small that you just have to be
really really smart with the football
and not beat yourself
and give yourself a chance going into
the fourth quarter and i'm looking
forward to it i know it's gonna be a
great super bowl match up regardless of
who uh whoever wins this next weekend
of the four teams that lost over the
weekend which teams in the best shape
coming back next year
oh man off the top of my head um
i always like new orleans and the reason
i do is because of sean payton i just
think that he's going to have answers he
always does so i
i like i like that group um i like i
like
sean mcvay and the rams i think they've
done a good job now
i i don't know that i'd say they're in
the best shape i think now there's some
uncertainty as far as
what's going to happen at quarterback
and then also uh
i don't know if it's been announced yet
sounds like they're gonna lose our
defensive coordinator
and uh and and he was in a lot of ways
the mvp of that team so yeah he took the
chargers job yeah
yeah so good hire for the chargers uh
he's been an impressive guy brandon
staley and uh and he'll be sorely missed
there in los
angeles for the rams if you were the
texans gm how would you clean up this
mess
well i think you got to first get on
board with quarterback you know
and i'm the last guy who would say that
the players run the organization and i
don't think deshawn watson does but
he's a great player and you'd hate to
lose a guy of his caliber i think that
that has to be mended somehow i don't
know what the communication was i don't
know what he was promised or
however that happened but i think that
would be priority number one
is making sure he understands that uh
he's going to be given every opportunity
to go out and have success i think
that's what every player wants that's
certainly what every franchise
quarterback wants
and uh and they have to be able to prove
that to him and satisfy
him in that regard because he's too
valuable to just let walk and
not have a replacement would you take
offers
yeah i would always take offers i don't
know that anyone would
ever be able to offer enough uh but yeah
i would certainly listen
if you ran the jets would you offer
everything
no i would not i wouldn't offer
everything well not a herschel walker
type train
here but but a herschel light how about
you know maybe three first rounders and
a couple of second rounders for deshawn
watson
well i dan i worked the draft when when
mayfield and darnold and those guys came
out uh
josh allen so i have a pretty good feel
for those quarterbacks before they even
got into the league and
and i think darnold is a really talented
guy i'm not willing to
give up on sam darnold now i would have
to study them and really
dig into it and see but i think the jets
have had a number of issues
and to pin that on darnold or say hey
the reason we've not been very good is
because we don't have a quarterback
i'm not willing to say that i i would
have to take a much
harder look and and maybe their
franchise quarterback is in the building
right now
uh have you ever had a player confront
you after something you've
said or said maybe a previous game
previous week previous year
when you go to a game location-wise oh
um not in a long time uh not in a long
time i i've had players at different
times who
have come into a production meeting and
had issue with something that i've said
um which i'm open to having a
conversation about i
i feel like i'm fair dan i think every
br i think every broadcaster
feels like they're fair right but i i
you know that you don't go in with an
agenda
uh but i'm i'm i'm willing to have a
conversation if i'm critical of a player
i feel very strongly in what i'm saying
so i'm i'm more than willing to have a
conversation as to why i said what i
said
and then if uh if i need to be corrected
if i thought maybe they were responsible
for something in which they weren't
because we don't
especially when you're talking about
secondary players you don't always know
uh sometimes it looks like it was this
particular guy and i
and i know coverages as well as anyone
but uh and i'll admit i mean i'll
certainly come out and uh
and you know make amends to it so it was
never go
time you never thought like somebody
wanted to get physical with you
no no i've never uh i i
i don't think i've ever said anything
that would have offended anybody
well it's early in the week troy so who
knows you know i don't know how about
you dan does anybody ever come out
uh yes a-rod a-rod and uh lawrence
taylor
wow yeah so we have something in common
with lawrence taylor
that's that's impressive those are hall
of famers coming after you
i i lawrence scared me i could see the
whites of his eyes through his dark
sunglasses
and i i thought he was coming after me
[Laughter]
have fun safe travels up there tell uh
joe buck we said hello always great to
catch up with you troy
thank you dad that's uh troy aikman
he'll be on the call a uh
fox will bring you the box and pack at
uh three eastern
that'll be on sunday